well okay so intelligence is paramount
right of course if you aren't smart then
you're gonna do dumb things and dumb
things can definitely get you killed
a really smart person
will get himself or herself the physical
capabilities that's what you'll do the
smart person the really smart person
will work their ass off to get in shape
and to stay in shape
because you can be smart to come up with
the most brilliant plan in the world but
if you don't have the physical
wherewithal to execute that plan then
that that brilliant plan doesn't matter
so yes you want to be smart and yes you
want to be physically strong you want to
exercise your brain and your body as
much as possible get yourself as
mentally strong as physically strong as
you possibly can
and that's not just in the not just in
the military
that's in life